si este hombre
chang lee se convirtió en el icono de la
toma el capitolio el 6 de enero tiene 34
años vivía en phoenix arizona y manejo
desde allá varias horas para poder
llegar a la capital y participar en esta
toma al capitolio donde se sentó en la
silla de la vicepresidenta de el senado
y trató de interrumpir en la oficina de
nancy pelosi se le conoce también mucho
por las demandas que hizo cuando fue
apresado dijo que quería una dieta
orgánica durante los 10 meses que ya ha
estado en prisión y también una
entrevista con el programa sixty minutes
el juez dijo en esta sentencia que
notaba un cambio en el comportamiento de
jake del chamán que llaman el chamán de
el 6 de enero no solamente por sus
creencias religiosas chamánicas sino
también por su creencia en la teoría de
conspiración cubano por eso varios le
dicen también llaman cubanos pero en
todo caso el juez decía que a pesar de
estas creencias a pesar de
de estas tendencias religiosas de esta
persona pues había notado un cambio ya
denota un cambio no solamente porque
había reconocido su culpa sino también
porque los abogados pues alegan que pues
se le debe reconocer en esta sentencia
también a la paga a este chamán que
tenía problemas mentales por eso
entonces la sentencia terminó siendo de
41 meses que a pesar de esto es la
sentencia más grande que se le ha
impuesto a una persona a una de estas
personas que reconoce su culpabilidad en
la toma del 6 de enero al capitolio